the Cuban National Assembly of people's
power has been in session for the last
three days top of the agenda Reviving
domestic food production which has
nosedived over the last few years
practically a hundred percent of food
Staples are being imported instead of
being produced in the country
six years ago forty percent of the rise
Cubans ate was grown domestically by
last year the figure had fallen to four
percent
U.S maximum pressure sanctions
introduced by Trump and left in place by
Biden are taking food off people's
plates they starve the country of
billions of dollars in Revenue every
year which means less money to spend on
fertilizer petrol and food imports
Cuba's policies focus on getting food to
those who need it most for example every
child under seven still receives a liter
of milk each day but the state's
capacity to Shield the vulnerable from
sanctions is diminishing for the last
two years around a million elderly
Cubans have gone without the vitamin and
protein supplements they're supposed to
receive
now triple digit inflation is hacking
into people's spending power a problem
that Maria Castillo is also aware of
she's just spent two days salary on a
couple of mangoes and some plantains
before the pandemic prices were
acceptable now prices have been Sky High
while Maria trusts the government will
eventually guide the country out of the
crisis for her 19 year old grandson
Denny the Communist party's words ring
Hollow
life in Cuba is bad there's hardly any
food you have to struggle to get by and
we can't live in Cuba anymore
president Miguel Dias Canal today called
on Cubans to use creative resistance to
overcome the country's problems and
boost production
what's your dream
[Music]
that my grandchild does something with
his life that he lives well but he
doesn't want to live here
and your dream to leave the country and
take my family with me Cubans emigrated
in record numbers last year and people
in the capital today increasingly doubt
whether the government has the ability
to get the country back on its feet
one way for the government to convince
more people to stay would be to get more
food on people's plates
Ed Augustine Havana Al Jazeera